hallo leute diese woche geht es bei
unserer super easy german serie über die
wichtigsten deutschen werben um das verb
gehen wir zeigen euch wie iris
konjugiert und in verschiedenen
zeitformen verwenden könnt und los
geht's präsenz ich gehe
du gehst er sie es geht wir gehen hier
geht sie gehen
hallo sophie adina wohin gehst du ich
gehe jetzt meiner oma und wohin gehst du
ich gehe noch kurz einkaufen
lasst uns doch später spazieren gehen ja
wobei mir spazieren gehen dass es in den
mauerpark gehen
ja das ist eine super idee ok dann bist
dann ich habe mir kurz janosch ab er mit
in den park gehen möchte ok
alina und ich gehen heute spazieren
möchtest du mitkommen
[Musik]
ja wir gehen so um 19 uhr
wir gehen einen mauerpark was so schön
aber das geht sich ich bin schon mit
caritas redet wird dieses ins kino
nutzen
schade aber schön dass ihr ins kino geht
ja danke tschüss janisch geht in den
whisky laden präteritum ich ging du
gingst er sie es ging wir gingen hier
gilt sie gingen wir gingen die straße
entlang online alina ich habe meine
tasche vergessen und dann gingen wir
zurück soviel woher kennst du deine
beste freundin
wir gingen zusammen in einer klasse in
der grundschule perfekt ich bin gegangen
du bist gegangen er sie es ist gegangen
wir sind gegangen ihr seid gegangen
sie sind gegangen hast du das gesehen
janosch ist ohne maske in den muskel
laden gegangen
ja habe ich gesehen das ging gar nicht
das ist noch mal gut gegangen
warum bist du gegangen ohne tschüss zu
sagen ich bin einfach gegangen weil du
mir auf die nerven gegangen bist du
jetzt bist du aber echt zu weit gegangen
janosch ist bei rot über die straße
gegangen
kultur ich werde gehen
du wirst gehen er sie es wird gehen wir
werden gehen
ihr werdet ihr hin sie werden gehen
erzählt uns in den kommentaren
ob ihr nach deutschland gehen werdet um
euer deutsch auszuprobieren
wenn corona vorbei ist werde ich wieder
hier in den klub gehen
wer kommt mit sophie wird jetzt die
treppe herunter gehen
jetzt wird sophie wieder zurückgehen so
viel werden wir heute noch etwas essen
gehen
das wird leider nicht gehen ich bin
schon verabredet ok schade konjunktiv 2
ich würde gehen
du würdest gehen er sie es würde gehen
wir würden gehen ihr würdet gehen
sie würden gehen
ich würde gerne schicken wir ihm essen
gehen
janisch könntest du uns mit diesem
fahrrad umherfahren
ja ich glaube dass wir gehen
ich würde in den klub gehen gäbe es kein
corona das war unser super easy german
video zum verb gehen wenn ihr jetzt eure
deutsch noch weiter verbessern möchte
dann empfehlen wir euch unsere apps
dort haben wir unter anderem einen
gender trainer bei dem ihr die 2000
wichtigsten deutschen normen und ihre
artikel üben können viel spaß dabei und
bis zur nächsten woche
[Musik]